- [DRock] Kevin Hart. Top Shot.
Tyler, The Creator
CryptoPunks.
Beeple
Pringles.
- Pringles?
- Hey everybody, it's GaryVee
and welcome to another episode
of overrated underrated with me, GaryVee.
(upbeat jazz music)
♪ Overrated or Underrated ♪
♪ What does Gary think ♪
- [DRock] Tyler, The Creator.
- I think Tyler, The Creator's underrated.
I've always thought he was
one of the most creative
people in the game.
I think he's a visually exciting artist
and I think that's cool.
- [DRock] Bang energy drink.
- Bang energy drinks are overrated for me.
You know, I've never enjoyed
the two that I've had.
They did a lot of very viral marketing
with early influencers, models,
fitness people on Instagram.
So I really appreciate the way
they marketed to build their way,
but I definitely am going with overrated
because I'm decided that
context I'm taking it in
is the actual beverage.
- [DRock] NBA Top Shot.
- NBA Top Shot is
Phew.
NBA Top Shot is
overrated in the individual NFTs,
like the individual cards.
And it's underrated as a project.
It's insane Roham and that team
did to launch that product.
Flow, the consumer
ability, the gamification
just underrated execution.
Like one of,
one of the things we'll look back on
as one of the early things
kind of like an app,
like a Yahoo, Ask Jeeves, or
Google, or YouTube like epic.
Overrated are the individual Top Shots
because it's like cards.
There's too much supply
demand issues coming
as the NFL, MLB UFC,
boxing, Muhammad Ali, Pelé
like everything in the
world is going to be NFT'd.
So right now, a lot of the energy
of sports and NFT go to this one project.
Like there's gonna be
people held with a bag
on a highlight of Terry
Rozier or making a pass
or like a solid dunk
by Jaren Jackson, Jr.
Like this is not like other, other
IP.
This is not Superman and Batman.
Like the player matters
- [DRock] Learning a new love language,
- Learning a new what?
- [DRock] I mean a new language. Wow.
- Wow, your love?
(DRock laughing)
- [DRock] No I said,
learning a new language.
- Did you learn a new love language,
DRock?
(DRock laughing)
Learning a new language is, overrated.
We have pods coming that
are going to do translation
plus I was terrible.
I got Fs in Spanish and German
consistently through my entire career.
So I don't fuck with
learning new languages.
- [DRock] Heavy metal.
- Heavy metal is for me
properly rated.
Because I actually think
heavy metals' underrated
because I don't think
it's really that rated to,
It's like fucking super
niche at this point.
Big shout out to Caleb.
- [DRock] Kevin Hart.
Kevin Hart's super underrated
like grinded his fucking way
to becoming one of the biggest movie stars
and entertainers in the world.
Fucking stupid,
stupid underrated.
Kevin Hart underrated.
- [DRock] The Mona Lisa.
- The Mona Lisa is overrated.
I subjectively do not find that painting
super interesting at all.
Art is in the eye of the beholder.
And I think like a Squirtle Pokemon
(Squirtle talking)
card is cooler,
than a Mona Lisa.
- [DRock] Pringles.
- Pringles?
I like Pringles.
I fuck with Pringles. I eat Pringles.
Pringles are underrated.
- [DRock] Owning a Website.
Owning a website is overrated.
It's what you do with
the website that matters.
It's like being an influencer.
It's like having an NFT project.
What you do with it is what matters.
Just having it means shit.
- [DRock] Beards.
- Beards?
I think they're properly
rated at this point, right?
Like, there was like,
it wasn't a thing during like
Friends, like the 90, right?
Everyone was clean shaven.
Then it became super hipster,
like 2005, six, seven, eight, nine.
I think it's settled into
properly rated at this point.
At this point, I don't think it's like
a passion one way or the other
- [DRock] Making your bed in the morning.
- The most, oh, I don't
think I've ever made my bed
in the morning in my entire life.
Making your bed in the morning
is wildly, wildly overrated.
You just go right back into it.
What? You like making your bed?
- [DRock] No, you just
go right back in.
- You just go right
back into it. That's just
a waste of fucking time.
I think some people enjoy
like it being fresh,
overrated.
- [DRock] Pretzels,
- Soft pretzels or like pretzels in a bag?
- [DRock] I think the
overall genre Pretzel.
- I'm gonna with overrated
even though I think soft pretzels
are underrated significantly.
I just think bagged
pretzels are so overrated.
Except those big ones.
Like the golden, I don't know.
You know, like the,
it's like the middle one the normal ones,
which is the majority of the industry.
(raspberry sound)
- [DRock] Istrian Wine.
- Austrian?
- [DRock] Istrian,
I-S-T-R-I-A-N Wine.
Istrian wine produced
in the region of Istria
- Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
I literally know of it.
Have never dug into it.
I have no answer for that.
- [DRock] Orange jui--
- Which I love by the way.
A wine question sometimes spent, right?
I just love the authenticity of the show.
What?
- [DRock] Orange Juice.
- Orange Juice.
Fresh squeezed, underrated,
regular ridiculously overrated.
There's a lot of context here.
- [DRock] Yeah. Okay
- I've had to break down multiple things.
Three things now, I've
broken into categories
which is unusual.
- [DRock] They normally,
they're normally a narrower topics.
- Now we're talking topics.
You know what? Real quick, hold on.
This macro micro thing, sending a text
212-931-5731
212-931-5731.
Hold on real quick.
Make sure you always break
down things in the micro,
and the macro
don't blend
the two.
The words of encouragement,
- [DRock] Credit Cards.
- Credit cards are overrated.
At this point, I'm swiping
my phone the whole time.
It makes my wallet feel heavier.
Overrated.
- [DRock] Abbreviations.
- Abbreviations? I think are underrated.
I love it.
I abbreviate everyone's names
and things of that nature.
I like a good abbreviation.
Underrated.
- [DRock] Popcorn.
- Popcorn is underrated,
especially if it has, yeast.
Do you know what,
you know, like the yeast
and popper, fuck with that.
- [DRock] Pickled foods.
- I'm Russian. Like pickled
foods are stupid underrated.
I love, I have a pickled.
What is this?
- [DRock] A pepper?
- No.
Okra or whatever yeah. Okra.
- [DRock] Oh, okra. Yeah okra.
I literally have a
pickled okra right here.
Underrated
shit.
- [DRock] CryptoPunks.
- Underrated. That's
all I'll say about that.
- [DRock] Horror movies.
- I don't fuck with Horror Movies.
So for me as like a fan
of consuming, overrated
but I really liked the genre,
(screaming sound effect)
the creativity.
So I'm going to go with underrated,
because I'm just looking
at it from that angle.
Me, I'm not a consumer of
like I did a little Friday
the 13th, a little, you know,
you know, Elm street.
There's been the modern plays
the Blum thing like, but Blum studios, but
underrated.
- [DRock] Cam Newton.
- Cam Newton is very underrated.
I really liked this guy.
You know, I'm super happy he's not a,
is he not a Patriot?
I think he's a cut?
I gotta, but like,
I was dead that he went to the Pat's
because I really love Cam.
I think Cam, you know,
what's great about being
in the business is
I have a good sense of
like who he is as a human,
I'm a big Cam fan.
I'm a big fan.
Cam Newton is a massively
underrated human,
creative as shit,
good dude.
Underrated.
- [DRock] Beeple.
- Beeple? Underrated.
He will go down as an iconic NFT artist.
Part of that first wave.
He'll be like the Tom of Myspace.
You know? Like in like,
like in the internet culture
like just so associated with something
and has really he's a young man still
has a huge potential to become
an iconic world artist.
- [DRock] Question of The Day.
- You have a question of the day?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- What that?
A little off speed pitch.
- [DRock] I thought we
do it at the end now?
- We do. Okay.
- [DRock] Remember?
- Yeah, I remember.
- [DRock] What reality TV
show would you want to go on?
- Survivor.
because I'd win.
- [DRock] That's our show.
- That is our show.
Thanks for watching.
Actually, you know what?
I'm gonna take questions
from my community.
212-931-5731.
Text me with what I
should put on next week's
overrated underrated.
When you text me put hashtag overrated
overrated, put hashtag OU.
O-U
Text me 212-931-5731
say pineapple and then space hashtag O-U.
Will be easy for me to find.
I will see our next week's
overrated, underrated.
YouTube watcher, what's up it's GaryVee.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also wanna to ask you,
please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration
of YouTube is about to
explode stories, polls,
more content, more engagement,
more surprise and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon.